we're joined on the line by House
Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy
congressman from California
representative McCarthy thank so much
for joining the show really appreciate
it man thank you for having me back it's
an honor so why don't we start with your
reaction to the latest developments in
Iran it is incredible to me to watch the
Democrat and media narrative which is
that apparently now the only reason that
war was averted is because the Iranian
regime is rational whereas President
Trump is a madman this is pure insanity
he was using basic deterrence strategy
that has been a hallmark of American
foreign policy for literally generations
and now apparently because that worked
and this gave the lights of the idea
that we had to pay off the Iranians to
be nice guys they're going to move on to
their secondary defense of Obama's
nuclear deal and Obama's of he's been
strategy which is that Trump is crazy
but the Iranians are rational would you
ever think for a moment that in a time
like this
that one political party would defend
Iran over America they would defend a
terrorist who had killed more than 600
soldiers what do they say to those Gold
Star Mothers what how do they defend
this and for the whole point that you
brought up it is working here was Iran
going around the entire region what they
do they shot down a drone they bomb
ships they bombed a refinery they killed
an American citizen and somehow the
president provoked something the
president sends a message goes after
those individuals who killed the
American what do they come back to come
back to our embassy so he sends a very
clear message where others who were in
that position were afraid to do to take
out the individual who should have been
taken out years ago send a very clear
message and what does Iran do Iran sent
some missiles but they made a point
almost we have no casualties I think it
was more from a political play of what
they wanted to do back home than
anything else it shows that the
president's strength is having them
really saying that in what's gonna
happen in the future we've been the
house Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy
congressman or Karthi there's been some
information floating around that the
Iranian government actually called the
Iraqi Prime Minister and warned him the
attacks were coming in to get the Iraqis
out of the way France and Finland
apparently knew about this as well is
there any information that the Iranians
were warning all of these parties
beforehand just that they would not
escalate the situation so they could
brag back to their people at home that
basically they had retaliated and they
had scared away the Americans while in
reality not
doing anything that would been enough to
provoke a response from the United
States I think when you look at past
behavior of Iran and others I think
that's exactly what they wanted to do
they want to tell the message back home
that they sent these rockets now it's
different in the past and using all
their proxies and trying to say they had
nothing to do with something when we
know it's always directed by them even
when there's their own weapon tree but
now descended from Iran say say to the
Iranian people that they shot back with
making a point to make sure that they
don't harm anybody at the same time I
think they had a great amount of fear
from our president that they knew they
could not do that now in other days I
mean think of the difference in
administration one administration gives
them billions to fund terrorism around
another one stop the terrorists from
growing you know the fact that the Obama
administration's narrative was basically
it was either appeasement or war this
has been debunked by President Trump now
because he took the third line which is
called deterrence I mean again this has
been a a massive part of American
foreign policy for the majority of the
existence of the United States
deterrence was taken off the table by
Obama Obama basically said the only way
that we are going to be able to avoid
outright war with Iran is to sign the
massive cheques and then allow them John
Kerry openly admitted this when he was
Secretary of State
to use that money to pursue terrorism
and ballistic missile development and
Trump comes in he says no this is all
nonsense we can deter these people and
we can do so by showing them that we are
not willing to allow them to do all of
this and the media's response is Trump's
a nut and the Iranians are rational and
thank God that the the ayatollahs are in
power so that they can stop World War
three from occur I mean this is it's the
media's narrative here is perfectly
insane but it's got to be springing from
this incessant defense of crap Obama era
policy it's exactly have we not learned
anything from the failures in history
the Chamberlain's the peace for our time
the appeasement of what happened it's
the exact same thing that went through
you know Ronald Reagan was here they say
you have peace with freedom you've got
to have both remember remember when
Ronald Reagan got up and walked away
from Iceland when he was meeting with
Gorbachev because Gorbachev wanted as
the end the SDI program because they saw
no freedom and right and so the idea
what happened because he did the Berlin
wall collapse here we go with a Barack
Obama what did he do with Iran when they
when they were having terrorism he gave
him billions of dollars to fund it
further and then he guaranteed them that
we'd support a nuclear weapon
after 10 years thank God for president
Trump stepping in and said no you're
never going to have a nuclear weapon and
if you continue to move and they region
the way you are we will push you back
and he sent a very clear message that
not only to the Ayatollah but to North
Korea and everybody else that he will
not tolerate he'll talk to you and he'll
try to have it on the basis of what
American believes in about freedom and I
didn't I do not believe at the end of
the day that history will be very kind
to what the Obama administration did
that is a low point was for the Middle
East and what happened tried to correct
the situation now and we're in a much
better place of doing when we were just
a few years ago House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy so congressman McCarthy
one of the slim reads that the Democrats
in the media have now been relying upon
now that World War three which was never
imminent is still not imminent now
they're relying on the idea that the
killing of kasama Soleimani was
violation of international law
suggesting that there was no imminent
threat that took place from soleimani
first of all you don't need an imminent
threat in order to kill a terrorist you
can actually just kill a terrorist but
beyond that have you been privy to any
intelligence about the the supposed
imminent threat that was taking place
from Soleimani we know he'd been
involved obviously in the attack on the
US Embassy in Baghdad he was in Iraq
coordinating with the forces that had
actually attempted to burn the embassy
what were there more imminent threats in
place
look I'm part of the gang of eight I've
been briefed on a lot there's things I
just do not talk about in that situation
but I think it's been very clear when
you look at what's all Maui has been
doing from where he was traveling from
all in the public domain of what what he
was planning in advance he already
killed an American he's already killed
600 of our men in uniform you look
behind an attacking of our embassy what
thanks for one moment if you could go
back in time and you could stop a
terrorist action before it started if
you've heard of what was going to go
forward this is the moment in time where
our president took that action what if
those times that Clinton missed killing
bin Laden what would have been the
change of history of where we were we
are safer today because our military
took action you think about where they
took that action at it also sent a
message anybody else if you plan these
different items for the future we will
stop you beforehand and we can
you anywhere he had complete authority
from article two you've got a terrorist
fighting and killing Americans inside a
war zone the president has a you
metaphor there are so many overlapping
responsibilities and protections for the
president to take that action it's
absurd that the Democrats would even
raise that issue and it's embarrassing
as an American that they would raise
that issue soon the House Minority
Leader Kevin McCarthy so to shift topics
a little bit here well actually rather
wildly let's talk about impeachment so
Nancy Pelosi
the Speaker of the House is still
deciding today whether or not to
actually convey the impeachment charges
over to the Senate I'm very unclear on
what her strategy here is just either
you convey it or don't you if you talk
to any Democrat they have the same
belief of you they have no idea what her
strategy is she does not have the power
to continue to hold it Mitch McConnell
has already set up where he has 51 votes
over there to move forward and you know
what Mitch McConnell's doing he's doing
a fair process that Bill Clinton and
Richard Nixon had the opposite of what
Nancy Pelosi did her case is so weak she
wants to change the structure make it an
unfair process and now they're asking to
have witnesses that in the house the
Democrats had all majority to pick
whoever they want to do didn't even
subpoena Bolton but now they think they
have to have it in the Senate
it just shows how weak this case is and
why this shouldn't even go forward and
really an underlying thing that I
believe your listeners should start
looking at as we're talking about Iran
and others think about the committee
that has the jurisdiction the
responsibility of protecting America
from all these everything the Intel
committee but what has the Intel
committee been since it's been under the
majority of the Democrats it's been the
impeachment committee with Adam Schiff
how many things have we missed because
we did not have the time to focus on
them of keeping America safe when they
had to take it out of Nadler put it in
another committee just to change the
structure in the system to try to ramrod
something that was the weakest thinnest
and fastest impeachment in the history
of this country
speaking of Democratic foreign policy
this is the same Speaker of the House
who decided to be a wonderful idea to
put congresswoman Ileana Omar on the
House Foreign Affairs it's unimaginable
that the American people would
really consider putting these people in
charge of foreign policy of the country
and the impeachment debacle really has
not proved to be much of anything here
do you think that if the Senate goes
forward with this process and they do
start calling witnesses that john bolton
should be one of the witnesses who
testifies look I don't think you have to
have any more witnesses the house part
makes the case the Senate judges on what
the case they bring forward why do you
have any more witnesses that the House
Democrats had all majority they changed
the structure where the minority could
not ask for witnesses they could ask for
anybody they wanted they told us they
were in such a hurry to move this that
it had to get done so soon judging on
its merit and I think what's going to
happen you're gonna have a majority over
in the Senate Republican and you're
gonna have Democrats join with them who
wrote against this I mean Jonathan
Turley who's one of the most respected
constitutional attorneys I know in this
country who is a Democrat who did not
vote for this president that the only
abuse and power is moving forward would
be with the Democrats if they move this
impeachment forward that it was the
thinnest weakest and fastest impeachment
in history yeah House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy I know you're busy I
really appreciate your time congressman
McCarthy good luck man you got a deal
with Nancy Pelosi everyday thank you Ben
take care
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content